le logiciel libre c'est un type de
logiciel qui ça remonte aux années 80 et
qui est définie par quatre grandes
libertés fondamentales qui est le droit
d'utiliser des logiciels mais par
apposition à des des logiciels
commerciaux traditionnels qu'il faut
acheter
donc on ne peut pas utiliser librement
mais avec également d'autres libertés
qui sont fondamentales par rapport à la
dynamisme que peut représenter le
logiciel libre c'est la possibilité
d'étudier le code source de ces
logiciels la possibilité de le modifier
et enfin la possibilité une fois qu'on a
modifié et en général améliorer un
logiciel libre existants de rediffuser
de façon à faire bénéficier le plus
grand nombre rediffusé les versions
modifiées de ses logiciels
le terme open source est arrivé un peu
un peu après en 98 email marie bonne
parce que il y avait essentiellement une
ambiguïté malencontreuse 1 dans la
langue anglaise on parlait de free
software et free software ça veut à la
fois dire logiciel libre et logiciel
gratuit autour de la fin des années 90
il ya d un certain nombre
d'entrepreneurs américains au début et
puis on avait aussi en france quelques
uns qui se sont dit que seul ses
logiciels libres en fait représentait un
matériel extrêmement intéressant pour
créer tout un nouvel écosystème tout une
nouvelle dynamique économique un peu par
opposition aux logiciels traditionnels
propriétaires dont on avait à l'époque
déjà sentir certain nombre de limites et
donc il est apparu intéressant et même
nécessaire de changer la dénomination de
faire en sorte de lever cette ambiguïté
entre logiciels gratuits dont qui ne
peut pas donner lieu à la création
d'entreprise création d'emplois autour
de ces logiciels est au contraire une
appellation nouvelle ou en les gens sont
inventés open source de façon à
au contraire légitimité légitimer toute
cette activité économique qui s'est
considérablement développée depuis la
fin des années 90 parce qu'en france
aujourd'hui au jour d'aujourd'hui on
doit compter à peu près 3 4 milliards
d'euros par an de chiffre d'affaires
autour du logiciel libre est
probablement entre 30 et 50 mille
emplois il ya un vraiment un besoin
d'embaucher des spécialistes du logiciel
libre qui sont formés par les
universités les écoles d'ingénieurs dont
certaines sont présentes sur le campus
de paris saclay